pour des questions de gestion des mines
et ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas vu
civile enfin très fait longtemps que je
vous ai pas eu ce que vous faisiez
camille son portable sur madame céline
c'est toi eric jamais fait ta vie
inquiète pas moi tu t'appelles taquet
passé décroche vous de bien sûr savard
et vous à quoi cette semaine eh bien ces
deux semaines j'ai envie d'avoir des
images de vous parce que moi je me suis
réveillée la semaine dernière du coup
ben j'ai fait que ça vraiment comme on
dit et donc c'est mon moment préféré
c'est le moment de vous présenter le
spectacle et de cyril encore plus fort
que notre dame de paris
en démarrant par as we say party plus
visuelle que les dix commandements voici
votre comédie musicale cyril c'est parti
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
cabanas le jazz
[Musique]
sans bagage oublié sur l'image
j'avais naïvement quoi quoi quoi quoi
[Musique]
amouroux d'amitié c'est vraiment une
très grosse on espère une version 2 1
j'ai hâte de la suite bien de suite oui
je bave j'espère je vous attends moi ah
non merde mais ça dépend que de vous non
non non je me cassais mobutu ya un bail
mais oui j'ai déjà les images façon pour
le 2 vous inquiétez pas merde voir
depuis quelques semaines binger révéler
votre grand secret un devant la france
entière
votre top cyril vous souvenez votre
petit tas de noms mais les français
devaient savoir
mais justement tellement je t'aime ou
féliciter parce que cyril ouvrez bien
vos yeux pas vous benjamin
et oui bonjour à benjamin bouhy d'avon
geste de questions l'élève a dépassé le
maître
ah bah oui oh oui mais oui oui vous vous
êtes salle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
il
toi qui dis bravo
[Rires]
dtc pas finie en revanche un nom parce
que benjamin lui c'est pas s'arrêter et
ça je ne cautionne absolument pas il ya
un gars qui tape n va eric benoist rossi
s'est hissé à l'eau ouais allô allô
tafer benoît à l'eau comme c'est baba là
c'est pas eric ouais c'est qui
ouais je te jure la vie de ta mère
[Applaudissements]
on embrasse le au contraire ils appelés
tubes salut mon frère c'est un copain
toi benoît rossi ils vont tout simple et
sympathie à toutes et à une meuf qu'il
appelait quatre fois maureen haut
[Applaudissements]
la pub tu as mis ton téléphone chez moi
j'ai chez l'indien olam et ça ils
habitent dans la gueule du loup casta se
venge de mathieu c'est la revanche des
meilleurs ennemis c'est parti
lui qui m'a lancé
j'ai embrassé lourd ce que tu fais
[Musique]
avons fait cet effet
[Applaudissements]
le gala
tellement bien non plus j'avais pajama
on va dire que la ola ray oui j'aimerais
dire bonjour ou nouveau chouchou
bonsoir fabien chérèque savoir mon sort
et sont les a prévenus fabien que
j'écoutais toutes vos conversations
pendant les pubs world
[Rires]
non mais j'ai vu que j'étais bien
intégrés en revanche à l'équipe 1 vous
avez déjà trouvé une personne avec qui
vous allez des atomes crochus à savoir
kelly petites chutes petite préférée et
d'ailleurs vous avez l'air tellement
heureux de cette nouvelle amitié
enfin regardez kelly
[Musique]
ce contrat
donc oui
la meilleure
parce que ces deux parts du rythme
pressé et bien chez moi je pense à sa
maman qui a 108 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne peut pas lui parler jamais discuté
avec moi jamais changé si vous avez non
j'aime beaucoup les gens lui les anti
rides et à la beauté fier ligne
intimidés par la personne ouais non mais
ça va venir
non donc un jouet c'est ça ouais trop
vite
allez allez trop vite rotor trop faut
aller sur tp family on encore des images
de votre pelle comment dire votre peau
respect entre vous l'amour qui lie à la
bienveillance l'entr'aide bon je vais
arrêter là parce que je peux être aux
montures voit donc la tp faiblit c'est
parti
[Musique]
mais
dans cette émission vous avez un défaut
vous parlez souvent de choses que vous
ne connaissez pas ce qu'ils aient jamais
mon cas lorsque je parle d'art à trouver
ses marques
les plumes en longueur
ah ah
[Musique]
juste plus de la journée surtout non ça
c'est mathieu
[Musique]
oui
devant les caméras
[Musique]
les chaires de woodstock et connaît les
chiffres de boules christophe jallet
l'aller chez les moules à toi de les
[Musique]
rencontrer mon téléphone métro jimena
l'émission je te vois mieux comme ça bat
encore plus jeunes
[Rires]
[Musique]
bien sûr que isabelle morini bosc qui
n'est pas la basse
[Rires]
ça c'est moi elle est très vivante
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'après 10 ans avec l'aide
d'autres choses mapuku bien sûr au road
book dans cette belle petite bande
eliane le psy de renommée mondiale si
elle arrive elle est compréhensive
toujours à l'écouté tout me be et bien
c'est le docteur qu'il y fait novelli ah
ouais allez hop on s'allonge sur le
différent c'est parti vous vous posez
des questions existentielles un petit
peu sur votre vie dans votre corps
reçoit
faut que tu restes dans cette situation
parce que faire attention
là elle te dis qu'elle pense comme toi
et qu'elle veut te retrouver mais elle
est à distance c'est facile de le dire
mais faut pas rigoler il faut juste
signer enfin signalé que ce sondage est
hyper important parce que dans tous les
cas tous qu'il s'agit de péter ou de
roter et à un moment donné pour le corps
et l'esprit c'est une des choses les
plus importantes pour ses autres biens
dans sa poche
[Musique]
suivant fait partie du magazine de la
santé ou si on est je vous dise
en fait ce qu'on peut non mais c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal tu comprends que vous
allez côté d'elle place non non je les
aime beaucoup
ah oui non franchement je suis bien là
bas très bien comme ça commence à
prendre mais nous avons d'autres choses
dans les duos de choc est plus
improbable
on a aussi mamiza et le petit mathieu
qui va pas là ce soir est odieux qu'il
me bourque
ah ouais non c'est pas vrai trailer de
la bourre mais pas que c'est maintenant
même si je ne fais pas tu ne parles tu
m'emmerdes tu me trouves tu m'emmerdes
tu parles trop ça mais merde
[Musique]
ton fils
ah bravo izard est de toucher un peu
cheap récupérer la food & lâché slam
[Musique]
vraiment les amis c'est moche qui se
passent très moche à trop long
[Musique]
en fait vous vous adorez sulfurisé à moi
j'aime beaucoup mathieu jeu c'est la
merde mais je sais je sais vous l'aimé
beaucoup et pour qui on a on a quoi
d'autre cyril vous pensiez que j'en
avais fini avec vous et bien pas du tout
il est le grand maître d'arts martiaux
de la télévision française et il est de
retour
c'est qu'il faut babar
[Musique]
voilà
ici là tu vois
[Musique]
la 4e fois tout ça dans la bulle j'aime
rester vodka non plus je suis désolé
c'est pas grave ça m'a fait plaisir
un cadeau on m'a parlé de trucs sur les
mauvais élèves pour qui c'est quoi ça ah
les mauvais élèves bien j'ai envie de
parler de jean-michel à alors s'il n'est
pas là aujourd'hui parce qu'il est parti
se faire liposucer il sera de retour
lundi complètement suseia jean-michel
effectivement mais il ya tous ceux du
groupe
oui le pont tous ceux du groupe donc
c'est donc les mauvais élèves
c'est parti en fait j'ai pas besoin
d'explications va découvrir tout ce sont
heureusement le soleil se connaît voilà
exactement en finale devant locataires
et compte y rester jusqu'à l'arrivée de
ses filles et ensuite il rentrera
convenablement ans
l'événement sera jamais moi qui empoche
le brésil
c'est ma vie
[Musique]
g
avi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certes il nous entoure
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les surfaces au dos mais dans l'instant
avec une dernière boucle qui on a une
dernière chose avant de passer au génie
du paf est au top huit matches et rien
sur si je vous demande le plus gros fail
au de l'équipe vous prétendez tous lors
du seul maire jean-michel et oui mais
pas être toute attente
eh bien il en train de se faire détrôner
dès lors vous ai remarqué mais par qui
par qui j'ai envie de vous le dire
eh bien je m'y attendais pas par un
homme intègre pourtant non mais bon
c'est pas c'est pas le cas voilà non
c'est pas lui absolument pas pas la
réponse en images à les organes passé
[Musique]
j'ai dirigé j'y vais doucement sur le
frein j'ai toujours peur un petit
mettait la [ __ ] douce
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous tendez beaucoup de choses de très
peu la main
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
faire liposucer jean-michel oui voila
merci c'est bien la première fois que ça
lui arrive en week end
[Applaudissements]
tu as préféré faire des couvertures
érotique faut savoir que c'est des
livres de poche
une nouvelle émission ghalem juste
[Musique]
il faudra se faisait directement